[Musique]
il aura tenu mille jours un record pour
la scène politique italienne
l'énergique matteo renzi symbole du
renouveau de la social démocratie en
europe s'est brisé sur son projet de
réforme institutionnelle avec un non
retentissant 59,11 % des italiens ont
rejeté sa réforme
un résultat dont se sont réjouies matteo
salvini
le président de la ligue du nord et
marine le pen en france
si cette révision ne présentait aucune
dimension européenne
le mouvement cinq étoiles de beppe
grillo et la ligue du nord ont
instrumentalisé cette consultation
comme un symbole du rejet de matteo
renzi de sa politique de ces réformes et
plus largement de l'establishment et de
l'union européenne
un discours qui a déjà permis de faire
basculer plusieurs grandes villes
d'italie dans le camp du mouvement 5
étoiles dont rome et turin
dans quelques jours un gouvernement
technique devrait être nommé par le
président italien après le vote du
budget
alors que d'autres échéances électorales
se profilent en france en allemagne aux
pays bas après le break site
l'élection de donald trump et le score
important du fp ou en autriche
l'ombre des nationalismes plane plus que
jamais sur l'europe
[Musique]